-Guys, it is the end
of the week,
and that's usually when I
catch up on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails,
and of course I send out
thank-you notes.
And I was just running
a bit behind,
so I thought, if you guys
wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out
my weekly thank-you notes.
right now, I hope
it's cool with you guys.
James, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?
Can you, uh...
♪♪
God, is he --
Is he animatronic?
Is that a real...
[ Laughter ]
Oh, there.
He moved his eyes.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you,
Tampa Bay Lightning,
for winning the Stanley Cup
on Monday night.
And for somehow doing it
with less fighting
than we saw Tuesday night.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, puffer coats,
for making me look like
The Rock in a t-shirt.
[ Laughter ]
He's just jacked.
Puffer coats or puffy coats?
What are we?
Puffer?
I don't think I've ever
called them puffer coats.
What do you call them?
-Uh, puffer coats.
-You just made it up.
-No, I didn't.
Yes, I did.
[ Laughter ]
-I knew you did.
I knew you did.
Okay.
♪♪
-Thank you, surprise
"Borat" sequel coming out
before Election Day.
It's nice to know
that no matter who wins,
we can all look forward to four
more years of co-workers saying,
[ As Borat ] "My wife."
[ Laughter ]
Let him do it.
♪♪
Thank you, Microsoft Word,
for suffering a major outage
this week,
or as Clippy put it,
"Well, well, well,
look at who needs help now."
[ Laughter ]
He gets a bad rap, Clippy.
He always helped me out.
I like Clippy.
-I love Clippy.
-Right?
-He's my home boy.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But then you had the option
to turn Clippy off.
-Yeah, but I liked him.
-You bring him back, right?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, you bring him back.
-Bring him back.
-Come on, man.
[ Laughs ]
Clippy.
-Yeah.
♪♪
-Thank you, knowing there's
a mosquito in my bedroom,
for providing me
with a fun night
of randomly slapping myself.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Imitating buzzing ]
♪♪
-Thank you, scented markers,
for telling you all
who the druggies
in the first grade class
would be.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
-"Jared, Jared, stop."
-Yeah.
-I like this one.
♪♪
This one you have to
really look at the graphic.
-Really?
-Yeah.
It'll be worth it.
It'll be --
This is almost like it's --
this is like AR.
XR. Multi screen type of stuff.
-Oh, okay, okay, okay.
-Yeah. This is like -- yeah.
Anyways...
Look at the graphic and also
listen to me.
-Okay.
-So it is like an --
it's an audio,
it's an audible, it's --
-I get it.
-Yeah.
-All right.
-Wait, at the same time, or --?
-At the same time?
Was that -- Yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
-At the same time, you're
going to look and listen.
Yep.
-Right now?
-Soon, yeah. Soon as I --
Soon as I can.
-Okay.
-All right. Thanks, Higgins.
-You ready? Let's do it.
[ Laughter ]
-Take that back, man.
-Oh, my God.
Take it like this.
♪♪
Thank you, hammerhead sharks,
for being a fearsome predator
that's also really good
at giving side-eye.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
That's really good.
♪♪
-Thank you, London Marathon,
for being held this Sunday
without spectators,
or as I'll put it on Monday,
"Hey, everybody, I ran
the London Marathon."
[ Laughter ]
There you have it.
Those are my thank-you notes.